So we can now update our test criteria subsumption. We start
from this situation in which there are no relationship between condition
coverage, branch coverage and statement coverage. And when we add branch
and condition coverage, we can mark the fact that branch and
condition coverage subsumes branch coverage
and also subsumes condition coverage, for
the same reason. Therefore, this is a stronger criterion than both
branch coverage and condition coverage, and of course indirectly also soft
statement coverage. So once more, to make sure we are all
on the same page, if I develop a test rate that satisfies branch and condition
coverage, the same test will satisfy also
branch coverage, statement coverage and condition coverage, necessarily.